This lecture is about evaluation of
text cluster.
So far we have talked about multiple
ways of doing text clustering but
how do we know which method works the
best?
So this has to do with evaluation.
Now to talk about evaluation,
one must go to go back to the clustering
bias that we introduced at the
beginning.
Because two objects can be similar
depending on how you look at them,
we must clearly specify the perspective
of similarity.
Without that, the problem of clustering
is not well defined.
So this perspective is also very
important for evaluation.
If you look at this slide and you can
see we have two different ways to
cluster these shapes.
An if you ask a question, which one is
the best or which one is better you actually see
there's no way to answer this question
without knowing whether we'd like to
cluster based on shapes or cluster
based on sizes.
And that's precisely why the
perspective or clustering bias
is crucial for evaluation.
In general, we can evaluate text
clusters in two ways.
One is direct evaluation and the
other is indirect evaluation. So
in directl valuation,
we want to answer the following
question:
How close are the system generated
clusters to the ideal clusters that are
generated by humans?
So the closeness here can be assessed
assessed from multiple perspectives
and that would help us characterize the
quality of clustering results in
multiple angles.
And this is sometimes desirable.
Now.
We also want to quantify the
closeness because this would allow us
to easily compare different methods
based on their performance figures.
And finally, you can see in this case
we essentially inject the clustering
bias by using humans.
Basically, humans would bring the needed or
desired clustering bias.
Now how do we do that exactly?
The general procedure would look like
this.
Given the test set which consists of a
lot of text objects, we can have humans
who create the ideal clustering result.
That is, we're going to ask humans to
partition the objects to create the
gold standard.
And they will use their judgments based
on the need of a particular application
to generate what they think are the
best clustering results.
And this would be then used to compare
with the system generated clusters from
the same test set.
And ideally we want the system results
to be the same as human generated
results, but in general they are not
going to be the same, so we would like
to then qualify the similarity between
the system generated clusters and the
gold standard clusters, and this
similarity can be also measured from
multiple perspectives and this will
give us various measures to
quantitatively evaluate a cluster
clustering result and some of the
commonly used measures include
purity,
which measures whether a cluster has
similar objects from the same cluster
in the gold standard and normalized
mutual information is a commonly used
measure which basically measures based
on the identity of or the cluster of
object in the system-generated results.
How well can you predict the cluster of
the object in the gold standard or vice
versa.
Mutual information captures the
correlation between these cluster
labels and normalized mutual
information is often used for
quantifying the similarity for this
evaluation purpose.
F measure is another possible measure.
Now again, a thorough discussion of this
evaluation, of these evaluations,
would be beyond the scope of
this course.
I've suggested some reading in the end
that you can take a look to know more
about that.
So here I just want to discuss some
high level ideas that would allow you
to think about how to do evaluation in
your applications.
The 2nd way to evaluate text clusters
is to do indirect evaluation.
So in this case the question to answer
is how useful are the clustering
results for the intended applications?
Now this of course is application
specific question, so usefulness is
is going to depend on specific
applications.
In this case, the clustering bias is
imposed by the intended application as
well.
So what counts as the best clustering
result would be dependent on
the application.
Procedure wise we also would create the
test set with text objects for the
intended application to quantify the
performance of the system.
In this case what we care about is
the contribution of clustering to some
application.
So we often have a baseline system
to compare with.
This could be the current system for
doing something and then you hope to
add clustering to improve it or the
baseline system could be using a
different clustering method and you
then what you are trying to experiment
with and you hope to have a better idea
for clustering.
So in case you have a baseline system
to work with and then you can add a
clustering algorithm to the baseline
system to produce a clustering system.
And then we're going to compare the
performance of your clustering system
and the baseline system in terms of the
performance measure for that particular
application.
So in this case we call it indirect
evaluation of clusters because there's
no explicit assessment of the quality
of clusters, but rather its to assess
the contribution of clusters to a
particular application.
So to summarize text clustering, it's a
very useful unsupervised general text
mining technique as particularly
useful for obtaining an overall picture
of the text content.
This is often needed to explore text
data.
And this is often the first step when you
deal with a lot of text data.
The second application or second kind
of application is to discover
interesting clustering structures in
text data, and these structures can be
very meaningful.
There are many approaches
that can be used for text clustering
and we discussed them:
Model based approaches and similarity
based approaches.
In general, strong clusters tend to
show up no matter what method is used.
Also the
effectiveness of a method highly
depends on whether the desired
clustering bias is captured
appropriately, and this can be done
either through using the right
generative model, the model design,
appropriate for clustering, or the
right similarity function to explicitly
define bias.
Deciding the optimal number of clusters
is very difficult problem for all the
classroom methods, and that's because
it's unsupervised algorithm and there's
no training data to guide us to select
the best number of
clusters.
Now sometimes you may see some methods
that can automatically determine the
number of clusters.
But in general, that has some implied
application of clustering bias there,
and that's just not specified.
Without clearly defining a clustering
bias, it's just impossible to say the
optimal number of cluster is what?
So this is
important to keep in mind.
And I should also say sometimes we can
use application to determine the number
of clusters.
For example, if you are clustering search
results, then obviously you don't want
to generate 100 clusters, right?
So the number can be dictated by the
interface design.
In other situations, we might be able
to use the
fitness of data to assess whether
we've got a good number of clusters
to explain our data well and to do
that, you can vary the number of
clusters and watch how well you can fit
the data.
If it's in general, when you add more
components to mixture model, you should
fit the data better, because you can
always set the probability of using the
new component at 0, so you can't in
general fit the data worse than
before, but as the question is, as you
add more components would you be able
to significantly improve the fitness of
the data and that can be used to
determine the right number of clusters.
And finally, evaluation of clustering
results and can be done both directly
and indirectly.
And we also would like to do both in
order to get good sense about how our
method works.
So here's some suggested reading, and
this is particularly useful to better
understand the how the measures are
calculated and clustering in general.